foreign
and Awning and Awning and Awning and
nothing has happened in this show so
what do you think I've forgotten
storing your deadly projectile launcher
this close to your fleshy erectile
launcher why did you join the resistance
beta well you see sometimes shows like
to bring in someone new to a situation
as an expositional surrogate for the
audience I thought that was kind of done
in episode one so now I'm just kind of
hanging around oh maybe I'll be part of
an important Mission this week in a
completely unseen role all faith
is built
on not so fast they are shkreli you're
forgetting about that pesky Faith that's
built on suppressing the masses through
the fear of a judgmental and omnipotent
higher power so by me I'm just gonna
hand these files to you in the most
unnatural way possible so this camera
and the attached audience can get a good
look at them also which genius with the
classified stamp over the caution notice
there's so much room on this thing why
stamp over one of the few bits of
information you actually need time to
change no I think the time to change
would have been almost any time that
wasn't as you're pulling up to the
military base and are clearly visible to
the surveillance cameras that are no
doubt surrounding it time in case you
confused it with New York cheesecake
1998.
scene of Nick Fury opening his umbrella
really fast over and over isn't
immediately followed by a scared flock
of birds that take down an airplane we
get it Disney you're really good at the
aging and you want to show it off but I
didn't need this flashback to justify
that Nick Samuel L Jackson Fury is a
sexual being this should put Jacob's men
on their heels wait who's Drake off okay
time for a quick googly google all right
General draykoff Marvel antagonist
introducing black
I totally forgot about that uh unit
doesn't exist Fury
that means I don't work for you that's
an intriguing possibility it's also a
stupid loophole if these guys want a
date then date I promise your
audience is even less concerned with
shelled rules on fraternization than
trade disputes in the Star Wars prequels
in fact I bet you'll be more concerned
with how I just said shelled
my friend looks a hell of a lot like
World War III
how can you watch that poison even a
broken clocks right twice a day I don't
know Fury what if a wild animal got a
hold of said clock let's say oh I don't
know a fox and what if this fox
up so bad that the poor clock doesn't
have hands or numbers anymore and
instead just spouts fear-mongering
hateful rhetoric with no basis in fact
or you know doesn't even tell time at
all darling you are Nick Fury stop using
his name as if you're reducing power now
stop it I never harbored any Illusions
about the necessity of you going away
but staying away
that leaves the mark okay but how long
exactly does he have to be away before
going away gets promoted to staying away
actually forget I ask I'm feeling a
sudden urge to stay away myself so blip
drinking orange juice immediately after
taking a drink of coffee you monster
what's next are you gonna tell me Nick
Fury brushes his teeth right before
drinking his coffee in the morning you
came back in the blue so glad we got
this CGI meat cute instead of Fury's
return from the blip seeing Fury
suddenly re-materialize in the middle of
New York City traffic would have been
the perfect time for Marvel's second
F-bomb I'm a good liar well she did
convince Darth Maul that Beckett was at
fault for Voss failing in his mission I
guess that counts so here's a sin for
Disney filling to give us a sequel to
Solo in which Emilia Clarke might have
been put to better use yes that was a
long walk but I'm happy to take it see
you tomorrow early oh early you say
thanks for that gravic for a minute I
was worried I'd have no clue when to be
ready for this very important Mission
but early clears that up entirely for me
it's remarkable in it covert meeting in
an art gallery cliche where all the park
benches mysterious Bridges and empty
church is booked by dead reckoning I
mean look at the fat smug smile on his
face are we looking at the same painting
or is that genuinely what constitutes as
a smile in England choice between having
my story told in ink and oil paint
or Avenue Written in Blood
I choose blood all day long yeah but
have you ever tried painting in blood
it's a nightmare you can never get the
right consistency you have very few
Shades to work with and I've just
realized that he's being metaphorical
and I may have drastically overshared
thank you love calling your server love
or darling or sweetie or any other pet
name it's not cute or respectful it's
creepy and annoying almost as bad as
leaving one of those Bible verse papers
disguised to look like cash is a tip
almost
[Music]
but what's the point of changing into
graphic it doesn't make the better
Fighters or give any real distraction
advantage since the real gravic is at
the table was it because you needed this
shot for the trailer to get people to
watch secret Invasion it was wasn't it
also I'm assuming this brick container
filled with Priceless pieces of art has
at least some kind of CCTV so why are
none of these numb Scrolls worried about
being exposed sudden ambush of also's
the fact that Talos is startled by the
appearance of multiple Kingsley benedirs
instead of aroused I mean amused yes
amused uh anybody have a glass of water
at hand uh I appear I appear to be
really thirsty ew stop it stop it stop
it seriously how do we live in a world
where this makes it past the sensors but
a classic Sam Jackson is
off the table also trying to convince me
that a butter knife is sharp enough for
gravic to cut his flesh with not only is
this blade too dull to stab through
gravic's hand but when he pulled it back
where the blade would have moved with it
in other words if you're gonna steal
from John Wick don't also also please
ignore any seeming correlation between
the above sin and the earlier sin about
painting with blood this is a work of
fiction any similarities two persons
living or dead or actual events is
purely coincidental Sirius is halfway
over and Emilia Clark has spent at least
66 percent of her screen time waiting in
cars
being the man of the world that I am I
have one English friend and they
informed me that Talos is carelessly
exposed himself here by eating the worst
part of the English breakfast first the
tomato is mostly decorative but if you
have to eat it you do so last so that
your final memory of that plate of
Grease was a marginally healthy one also
whichever animal decided this poor man
deserved to have his toast with extra
carcinogen sprinkles also also where's
the black pudding and the beans and the
sausage and what Maniac has a coke with
a full English this is an outrage what
an absolute bunch of cup whoa whoa whoa
I am not reading that okay maybe it was
a mistake to let my English friend send
this entire scene
Talos
full disclosure everyone I may have
focused too much on the breakfast sins
because I have no idea why Fury is no
longer mattitelos what was that you
actually did pay attention and you're
wondering the same thing sweet back to
the breakfast sins then using far too
much imaginary currency to pay for your
disappointing breakfast I mean just name
me one Alba into species relationship
where it's acceptable to clean up the
other guys poop Peace Lily and a betta
fish plant feeds off the fish waste and
cleans the water fish eats the plant
roots any other questions Taylor's I
mean every time you were promoted inside
Shield
we did that every terror attack you
prevented we did that every Talos does
that for all the sometime I mean did
that for all of the sometime I mean this
does this that we did that thing he does
it look The Scene goes on for a bit okay
you got any more abuse want to hear on
my way mistaking the truth for abuse so
I just left you why did Talos turn back
into his human form what's the point of
being able to look like anyone you want
if you just pick one identity for these
secret missions Fury kills the guard on
site which is totally cool because he's
a scroll and those refugees am I right
but did Fury know that for certain if
not then he just murdered a British
officer who was literally just doing
their job and post 1777 that's rather
frowned upon
kids covert communication devices that
have bright lights make sense if you
want to spoon feed the audience how
you're speaking to your buddy makes less
sense if you're practicing top tier
spycraft nobody calls me Nick Bob
technically everyone calls you Nick
every person who's ever referred to you
by your full name has called you Nick
they just use your surname immediately
after it also I haven't rechecked the
whole MCU but I guarantee that he's been
called just Nick I'm even willing to bet
it'll happen this series this is not a
negotiation Bob it is because you're
gonna counter his offer by releasing his
kid after Bob releases Talos it's not
not a negotiation just because one side
has more to negotiate with what you're
working on over there Bob the
implication here is that a military
commander can track the position of a
submarine carrying nuclear missiles from
a home computer and I'm just gonna go
ahead and call Bull scroll on this whole
thing I hope I can protect you you
couldn't protect yourself coming through
that door Bob would be excellent at
Taylor's sins why don't you shape-shift
back into this piece of trash and call
all in on abort on that missile strike
maybe cause he's the only one who knows
the code word making Furious dumb as the
audience so that we'll understand the
plan but accidentally making him dumber
than the audience who clearly figured
out it wouldn't be as easy as this
through context clues also a fury really
thought stopping the missile was as
simple as Talos making a phone call why
was he bothering to interrogate Bob in
the first place
these are centcom's orders with him obey
or you'll be removed okay so the launch
of this missile will require both of
these guys to scan their key cards and
flick some switches so why didn't gravic
replace this clearly hesitant officer as
well as this first guy having said that
did he need to replace either of them if
the orders are coming from Commodore Bob
then wouldn't they be followed
regardless enough of this bull shots
also continually preventing Samuel L
Jackson from cursing I've just about had
it with this monkey fighting censorship
on this Monday through Friday show I'm
giving you three seconds to give me that
code or I'm gonna aim higher or maybe
lower is that threat really carry as
much weight on a scroll we've seen them
change their shape and even Mass so
couldn't they just temporarily relocate
their dangly bits you can't even keep
your daughter's loyalty Talos is all
about pacifism until somebody mentions
his daughter and then he goes all Marty
McFly don't call me chicken or Batman
why did you say that name or Will Smith
at the Oscars I'm not really sure why
considering his alternate course of
action after killing this guy ironically
puts his daughter at extreme risk
hang on that shot wouldn't instantly
kill a human is that where a skrull's
vital point is and that raises another
question when a scroll shape-shifts into
a human externally do all their vital
organs stay in the same place on the
inside damn it Marvel you're creating
more questions than answers again this
guard is one of the worst guards to ever
guard and instead of coming up with a
clever way to beat this man while he's
down well just let his work speak for
itself
having this many memories about soccer
It's just sad England Bob I mean that's
just sad Bob a boat exercise
code word
Zachary fortunately for planet Earth the
commodore's password was essentially
password alright so
make me understand
I'm not with gravic because I'm with you
roses are red violets are blue may I
offer you a meaningless platitude or two
I hear the first thing they teach you at
motorcycle school is to immediately hit
the deck at the first sign of any
oncoming headlights it's really the
safest thing to do are you a leader of
Scrolls
rough way to go but still beats her Game
of Thrones Arc
what if you think she's dead why bother
driving around the body what possible
reason could you have for swerving like
this ooh safety deposit box mysterious
gun ominous phone call what could it all
mean spy is half
English food I actually ate a kidney I
sent three operatives to infiltrate the
Royal Navy
as a rule that you know Commander
station and operatives cannot be why do
we feel it's necessary to yak about
[Music]
saying his late 50s taking a hard long
look across a crowded room your father
called for a party
that's the one Pauline oh I'm sorry I
forgot I live in this world you live in
a psycho bunker where 911 was an inside
job and and the government are all Nazis
the government are all Nazis
I was wondering what would break first
your spirit all your money
my name is Zeus Zeus yeah Zeus as in
father of Apollos Mount Olympus don't
put mirror ourselves a lightning bolt up
your ass Zeus I'm sorry I didn't realize
that I think
I think curse you're sudden but
inevitable betrayal
oh no God
what's in the box